Let's jump into some mesh optimizations now
So the first thing you want to do in your DCC app
Whatever you might be using whether it's a mayor or max or another software you want to make sure
UE 5
correlates to your grid inside this DCC system, so
UE 5 uses centimeters for unit measurement. So one unreal unit is one centimeter
So just make sure your scene is set up and scaled to centimeters in your external package there
When looking at the use of Nanite, which is Unreal Engine 5's
new mesh based system, you can see that when we have a
proxy mesh
That that fidelity especially on that wood grain gets lost a little bit
But as soon as we have a Nanite mesh where we're getting this extra level of fidelity and we're throwing
Everything at the scene and an Unreal Engine 5
Can handle millions of polygons
Being thrown at the scene and it will make some affordances and some optimizations to how the meshes are rendered
But you can see a really strong use of why you might want to use Nanite on your meshes here
So to talk a little bit about Nanite you when you import on the FBX options
You can build Nanite for the per asset basis on your import FBX settings
Then in your static mesh editor, so when you double-click the static mesh from the concept browser
You can see the details panel and you'll see the the Nanite settings here and whether it's enabled and then
You've got a couple of different options that you can change that and then you can also create
Geometry collections which Nanite can batch certain assets together
So if we select a few different assets and we say okay Nanite enable enable Nanite here
We can then have collections of this geometry that are grouped together
Which Unreal can then make some affordances for as well
So Nanite isn't supported just out of the box on every single
mesh type
Nanite works
Fantastically on the static meshes and instance versions of static meshes and hierarchical instance of static meshes and also
Geometry collections. However, we can't support skeletal animations right now
morph targets or any world position offsets and materials
Spline meshes custom depth or stencils vertex painting on instances any decals
or custom
UVs these are not currently supported
So again, if you're trying to do any kind of transparency or skeletal meshes anything like this
Unreal doesn't currently support Nanite out of the box, but for any kind of fixed static mesh based geometry
Nanite works excellent for that. When looking at
Optimization as well. We want to think about limiting overdraw. So especially on this foliage actor, for example
You can see that unreal even though
We've technically got a bit of asset in every
Box here. Well, we'll end up getting a little bit of overdraw
especially when we've got these layered on top of each other and
Unreal needs to render something behind this static mesh for example
So on the right hand side here
You can see that we've tried to optimize the plane a little bit just to say okay only render
What's within this surface here and therefore if we're looking at this right hand image and on the left top left hand side of that
Image you can see that if there was something placed behind that and we all would render that first and it would render it
Without an extra alpha render pass so you can instantly see that especially as these layers stack up
You get a lot more
Well, you're limiting the effects of overdraw depending on the complexity of the scene
So really good to consider just how how you're laying these
Static mesh planes and you're seen and making sure you're trying to limit that overdraw
And then you can also make some level of detail adjustments. So
if you get a default reduction
On your mesh here, you'll see that
Deforms the mesh a little bit
Maybe this is okay for your default reduction again level of detail depends on what you need from your scene
but it's a good setting if you
Have some bone priority reduction so that it preserves that mesh a little bit
So a level of detail of meshes can be found on lots of different types of meshes
However, again, it's up to you which approach you take there